[Music]
what's another oppressive dictatorship
to series protagonist Rico Rodriguez not
much he does encounter a new kind of
enemy and just cause for however extreme
whether it's the common thread that runs
through both the story and new mechanics
and tops off the explosive spectacle the
series is known for and alongside new
gadgets to send objects and people
flying across the world
Just Cause has become a physics
playground unfortunately there just
aren't enough opportunities to put these
features to good use underwhelming
mission structure and a world slim on
enticing activities make just cause for
a short live blast with untapped
potential a strong point of Just Cause
games is at the forefront once again an
exceptional traversal system lets you
propel Rico across the beautiful
landscapes of solis and effortlessly
soared through the skies with the combo
of a grappling hook parachute and
wingsuit Rico can basically go wherever
whenever and often more efficiently
without a vehicle it's tough to
overstate how satisfying it is to escape
enemy hordes and hook onto the underside
of a helicopter to hijack it and tear
them all down or slingshot yourself out
of harm's way toward your next target
Rico isn't only built to move fast
however if you aren't causing explosions
you might be doing something wrong fuel
tanks red barrels and vehicles are
unusually explosive and set the stage
for over-the-top action since the
grappling hook can also be used to
tether objects together you have lots of
opportunities to get creative
outside of exhausting your arsenal of
firearms some weapons just wreak havoc
such as the railgun or burst fire rocket
launcher and even modest small arms like
the SMG have impactful alternate fire
modes
[Music]
it's identity as a destructive sandbox
is further emphasized by grappling-hook
mods three of which you can customize
the air lifter retractor and boosters
all three devices coincide with the new
physics engine airlifters essentially
many hot air balloons let you launch
things into the sky and they could be
further customized in terms of velocity
behavior and altitude retractors pull
targets together violently and boosters
work like jet engines that'll send
objects into a speeding frenzy whether
it be an attack helicopter or a poor
enemy soldier multiple permutations of
these contraptions are made possible
since their effects can be stacked into
a single tether and three loadout
settings let you switch between the
loadouts on the fly however this leads
to the most disappointing part
Just Cause 4 gives you so many new shiny
toys to play with but seldom a reason to
use them mission structure is uninspired
as you continually ask the escort NPCs
defend a specific object for a set
duration activate or destroy
inconspicuous generators or hit a number
of console panels to activate some sort
of process the worst offender has to be
the timed missions to ask you to sync
bomb rigs vehicles into the ocean
they're tedious and prone to mishaps at
no fault of your own
while blasting through waves of enemies
and their military great vehicles offers
some great moments often asking yourself
ok what else
shielded heavies snipers perch from a
mile away and flocks of attack
helicopters can become enjoyably
overwhelming since it's a chance to
rapidly make use of your diverse toolset
but several missions are designed in
such a way that's oddly restricting
limiting the game strongest assets and
we simply swarm and act as basic
obstacles rather than clever challenges
and that leaves you with objectives that
rarely bring out the best in the
mechanics and systems of Just Cause 4
there are a few stellar moments in the
main story missions that make proper use
of the extreme weather system that is
the core of Just Cause 4s premise
specifically the conclusion to a storm
chaser theme questline funnels you
through a number of battles while its
horn atoll rips through your
surroundings
your ability to parachute and glider
drastically affected by the wind
velocity and turbulence which throws
some welcomed unpredictability into the
mix destroying massive wind cannons with
boosters wasn't only the most efficient
method but watching these heaps of Steel
frantically spin out of control was a
sight to behold the last stand in this
mission a sequence of rooftop firefights
amid the harsh weather brings the many
great pieces of the game together
the same can't be said about the other
extreme weather conditions however
sandstorms challenge you with violent
winds and obscure vision and
thunderstorms bring on torrential rain
and lightning strikes that make for a
visual treat but they have a minimal
effect on gameplay even then the
questlines tied to these weather
conditions and the respective biomes are
over well before you can fully
experience their unique qualities
throughout the game you'll be building a
revolution across solis bolstering
what's called the army of chaos which
serves as a tool for controlling
territories across the map
this also gates your ability to take on
story missions it boils down to a
numbers game and once you understand the
structure of the system you can easily
snowball squad numbers and control all
of soul ease without having to grind
your chaos level side activities a
litter the map as well team with NPCs to
destroy enemy infrastructure do wild
stunts or too simple puzzles to learn
more about Solis it's more things to do
and they unlock grappling-hook mods but
they're simple in nature and aren't
enough to compensate for the
shortcomings of other missions just
cause 4 has incredible moments where
beauty and destruction crossed with
Rico's ability to zip around the world
at a moment's notice it's gratifying and
easy to grasp especially when you're
able to string a series of wingsuit
flybys vehicle hijackings and fiery
explosions all in the name of revolution
but those moments are either short-lived
or tied to rudimentary missions
you're given an awesome toolset that
paves the way for creativity in a world
with too few problems to solve at a time
when open-world games sometimes overstay
their welcome just cause four is at the
other end of the spectrum where you wish
there was more to experience because it
has so much going for it
[Music]